hey 42 here have you ever had a song get
so hopelessly stuck in your head
that you find your unconscious mind
keeps slipping back to it again and
again throughout the day
the germans have a word for this kind of
mercilessly catchy tune
or them meaning ear worm and
as i'm sure you're aware when an ear
worm wiggles its way inside your brain
it can be incredibly difficult to
dislodge it
luckily it seems a human race has enough
scientists knocking
around these days that we can spare a
few from
curing cancer and fixing climate change
to study vitally important topics
like ear worms and according to some
recent research
bad romance by lady gaga is the world's
deadliest ear worm
closely followed by the aptly named
can't get you out of my head by kylie
minogue
and then don't stop believing by journey
if you've ever been afflicted with one
of these dreaded ear worms or others
like them
you'll know how incredibly annoying it
can be both for you
and those around you right when you
least expect it you're tapping your foot
whistling inanely
or wiggling your hips like a dad on the
dance floor but
imagine if the urge to move your body to
a song nobody else could hear
became so strong you were rendered
literally
powerless to resist its silent rhythm
that you were so compelled to do the
funky chicken whilst waiting in line at
the supermarket
you would drop all 96 rolls of toilet
paper you were planning on stockpiling
to start dancing uncontrollably for
hours on end
that might sound like something out of a
bad comedy film but
believe it or not it really can happen
picture the scene in a sleepy town
during the height of summer
a young woman suddenly begins dancing
enthusiastically for no apparent reason
your modern mind may already be assuming
she's just come out of an all-night rave
peeled up to her eyeballs but no because
our story takes place in 1518
and neither all night raves nor mdma
had been invented yet the sleepy town by
the way
is strasbourg which is found in france
today but in those days it was part of
the holy roman empire
and during that summer half a millennium
ago
it was to be the site of one of the most
bizarre medical emergencies in history
a dancing plague no doubt happy for some
free entertainment
a small crowd gathered around the girl
as she started pulling
shapes but after a while the onlookers
began to grow restless
you see hours went by and the girl was
showing no signs of stopping
days passed and she was still at it
the townsfolk were understandably
concerned
and that concern was transformed into
full-blown panic
by what happened next other people
started joining in
by the end of the first week there were
no fewer than 30 people dancing
energetically
in the streets of strasbourg for no
apparent reason
the council were forced to step in but
unsurprisingly
they didn't have much experience with
spontaneous outbreaks of bad dancing
so without any real idea of what to do
they
improvised unlike spontaneous dancing
i can think of countless reasons why you
should treat your hair loss
early on by using keeps who've kindly
sponsored today's video
i've had people close to me start to
lose hair as early as their twenties
and it's always been an upsetting
experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone
did you know two out of three guys will
experience some form
of male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now
and do something about it whilst you
still have hair left
i remember when you had to go to the
doctor's office for a hair loss
prescription
but now thanks to keeps you can visit an
online doctor
and get the medication you need
delivered directly to your door
i really like keeps because it makes
treatment super easy by delivering your
hair loss medication
every three months so you can say
goodbye to
awkward doctor visits and waiting in
pharmacy checkout lines
if you're like me you're probably not
ready to lose your hair just yet
but prevention is key the faster you act
the faster you see results
and the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you'll save
if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash
42 or click the link in the description
to receive 50
off your first order perhaps following
the logic that
you can make a fire burn itself out
faster by adding fuel to it
officials ordered that a stage be
hastily erected in the town square
in the hopes of helping them get
whatever it was that was compelling them
to dance
out of their systems but unfortunately
whilst adding fuel to a fire can indeed
make it burn out faster
it's also liable to make a bigger fire
before long as many as 400 people had
been taken by the dancing plague
nobody knew what was causing it and
there seemed to be no way of predicting
he would be afflicted next those of you
who've spent the odd night on the town
engaging
in furious dance-offs and generally
tearing up the local dance floors
will know what it's like to come home
with sore feet
but unlike clubbing enthusiasts today
the people of strasbourg
weren't able to go home at 2am to wallow
in bed spin and regret
they were dancing round the clock they
didn't stop to eat
drink or sleep their feet were soon
bloody and torn and their faces were
warped by
fear and pain and then
the dying started according to some
reports
at the height of the dancing plague of
1518 which lasted almost two months
as many as 15 people danced themselves
to death
from exhaustion and heart attacks every
single
day what started out as a curiosity
quickly became a terrifying epidemic
that could strike anyone
anywhere without warning it was
basically like corona
but with a lot more people doing the
worm now i'll admit it this all sounds
insane and i'd forgive you for thinking
i'm making it all up
but i'm not multiple independent records
survive
confirming this strange event really did
take place
and what's more it isn't the only time
it's happened
the earliest known dancing plague hit
central europe in the 7th century
and outbreaks continued to appear for
the next thousand years or so
incidents were reported in england
germany italy
switzerland and the netherlands and the
largest was said to affect more than a
thousand people at one time
in the 13th century one famous case saw
a large group of children
travel some 20 kilometers between the
german towns of earth fort
and onstart jumping skipping and
dancing all the way if that's ringing
some kind of distant childhood bell for
you
you might be interested to learn the
story of the pied piper of hamelin
originated at the same time also in
germany some historians believe that's
more than just a coincidence
okay so what exactly was causing all
these people to
shut up and dance at the time the
unsavory business in 1518
was just put down to either overheated
blood
or demonic possession now i'm no doctor
but i think we can safely rule out both
of those
demonic possession just isn't a thing so
that part's easy enough and i'm pretty
sure
if your blood gets too hot you don't
suddenly turn into michael flatley on
amphetamines
you just die one theory is that the
strasbourg outbreak was caused by mass
food poisoning
i've had food poisoning before and i can
tell you
dancing was the last thing on my mind
but
this particular brand of food poisoning
was caused by ergot fungi
which can be found growing on various
grains like rye wheat and barley
ergot contains a rather interesting
alkaloid
called ergotomy which probably doesn't
mean much to you
but if i told you lsd was originally
synthesized from ergot fungus
you can probably see why it might be
relevant to a bunch of people freaking
out
at the world's first invisible rock
concert it's a nice theory but it
stretches plaur's ability to suggest
upwards of 400 people
accidentally got high on a medieval
version of acid
and all had the same very strange and
very bad
trip so i think we can probably rule
this one out
too other theories include diseases
familiar to us today like
encephalitis epilepsy and typhus
but whilst each of these could explain
some of the weirdness going on
none of them quite cover all of it a
string of similar outbreaks in southern
italy in the 16th and 17th centuries
was linked to the bite of the tarantula
wool spider
according to local traditions those
bitten
had to perform a vigorous dance for
hours on end
or even days in order to save themselves
from the poison
the hysterical dancing that ensued was
known as tarantism
if you're one of those strictly come
dancing types you might have even heard
of the modern day dance
that evolved out of this odd curative
jig the tarantella
harry potter fans may also recognize the
word jk rowling borrowed it
when naming one of her spells taryn
telegra
which causes uncontrollable dancing
anyway this whole
italian spider dance thing is somewhat
mystifying
again i don't come armed with a medical
degree here but i'm pretty sure
everyone in history who's tried to cure
themselves of poisoning
by doing the macarena died in the
attempt
and even weirder this particular kind of
wolf spider isn't actually all that
venomous in the first place
sure you'll want to steer clear if you
happen to be an insect or a worm
but if you're a standard issue human a
bite from a tarantula wolf spider
is no worse than a bee sting there's
really no need to jump out of your seat
and start twerking like your life
depends on it incidentally the spider in
question here
lycosa tarantula isn't actually a true
tarantula belonging to an entirely
different
infra order but oddly enough it was the
first spider to bear that name
so all actual tarantulas are named after
it
weird okay so if it wasn't fungus or
spiders
and if no virus or disease we know of
could account for all of these symptoms
why the hell was everyone dancing well
the truth is
nobody knows for sure it's possible
there was some
unknown pathogen wreaking havoc across
europe in the middle ages
but there's another much more likely
explanation
that despite the fact people were
dancing themselves to death
physically there was nothing wrong with
them at all
instead they were suffering from a
psychogenic
illness mass psychogenic illnesses
are essentially physical symptoms that
affect a group of people
in the absence of a known physical cause
they're effectively a kind of psychic
epidemic
and though they have no physical
component like virions or bacteria
they seem to spread just like regular
diseases
meaning if you come into close contact
with someone suffering from a
psychogenic illness
you might just catch it too it may well
be the case that some of our strasbourg
dancers really were suffering from the
effects of a traditional
illness but the vast majority of those
other 400 people
were just joining in they saw what
looked like a terrible disease infecting
their friends and family
and the very belief they were witnessing
some genuine affliction
was enough for them to catch it even
though it never actually existed in the
first place
as crazy as it may be to suggest someone
could dance themselves to death
just out of a compulsion to take part
i'm willing to wager most of you
watching this video have experienced
symptoms similar to a psychogenic
illness in the past
even if on a less dramatic scale if
head lice ever went around your school
you probably know what it's like to feel
itching all over your scalp
even when you know you aren't infested
then there are those weird coughing fits
that sometimes go around assembly halls
or in theaters before the curtain goes
up someone starts it and before you know
it half the room is coughing away
you don't need to cough but now that
it's in your head
you really really want to
of course there's a bit of a gap between
an itchy scalp or tickly throat
and dancing till you quite literally
drop but
the middle ages also provided in
abundance a secret ingredient
that's forced to have funned the flames
of mass psychogenic illness
stress these times were hard in a way
many of us today
would have trouble even imagining sure
it's pretty stressful when your boss is
a dick
or your landlord puts the rent up for
the third time in a year but
it's safe to say it's probably worse
when the bubonic plague
kills more than 50 percent of the people
on your continent or drought causes your
harvest to fail for the second year
running
and you're forced to decide which one of
your children you like the most
in many of the areas afflicted with
dancing plagues
the people were living on the ragged
edge of human endurance
and every once in a while they snapped
in strange and tragic ways whilst no
dancing plagues have been reported for
300 years or so
mass psychogenic illnesses are a lot
more common than you might think
even in the modern world at the end of
january in 1962
on the edge of lake victoria a school
run by a christian mission
was about to become the epicenter of its
very own
psychogenic epidemic it started with
three girls giggling away in a corner
and ended with students across the
region suffering from
uncontrollable fits of laughter that
lasted for days on end
the whole thing took some 18 months to
burn itself
out shutting down 14 schools and
affecting more than a thousand children
in the process
and in 2001 a man carried out what
some thought was a terrorist attack in a
subway station in maryland
spraying an unknown substance into the
air when 35 people were treated for
nausea
headaches and sore throats in the
aftermath there was genuine worry
something deadly had been released into
the atmosphere a chemical weapon perhaps
nope the guy had been armed with window
cleaner
it's worth pointing out that whilst mass
psychogenic illnesses like these
don't have a traditional cause that
doesn't mean the people experiencing the
symptoms
aren't suffering from genuine physical
issues
as morpheus says to neo in the matrix
after our hero
belly flops 70 stories straight into the
tarmac
and wakes up with a bloody mouth your
mind makes it real
just like your itchy scalp during the
great headlight outbreak of 96
once your brain starts whirring it can
be almost impossible to tell the
difference between the real
and the imagined so yeah next time you
notice someone
idly tapping their foot when there's no
actual music playing
just stamp on it you never can be too
careful
thanks for watching thanks again to
keeps for sponsoring this video
don't forget to try it out using the
link below